the aspirin beat us those are Greek
mother's alphabetical then Alfred b2b
the roots of the quadratic equation x
squared plus X minus 1 into 0 find the
value of alpha to the power 6 plus beta
to the power of 6
we're going to do that so when we have a
look at this idea over here we introduce
knees we should use these quadratic so
we said okay you can find where these
roots are like well they're talking
about this quadratic rigidly and they're
just giving the roots and names okay how
are we going to work out what this thing
is why don't even have the taro sticks
you know I'm going to ask you a little
something
now this is an idea again you're
actually going to encourage next year so
this is kind of a nice little warm-up to
that I want you to consider a quadratic
equation any quadratic equation so
what's the general form of a quadratic
equation start with hey a x squared plus
BX plus C if there's a general form of a
quadratic which that could be anything
okay yeah that's for that anyway so
you'll notice that the right-hand side
I've set up to zero as opposed to why
something like that right if the
right-hand side is 0 what will this help
me find why would you make this equal 0
what does that achieve if you see the x
intercept it gives you the roots the
places where your parabola intersects
with the x axis okay so consider this
now I don't know what the roots of this
thing are okay I don't know where they
are because x squared plus BX II could
be anything right but what I do know
I'm fightin roots if I can put it into a
factor at all right if I can see some
structure underneath and then I can work
out I would think it to negative 3 or
positive 3 negative 3 or whatever is
okay so I can write this this can be
rewritten if it did factorize form with
the roots right then if there were
something like X minus a number as X
minus some other number and those other
numbers will be the roots
now this Chapman tree problem has opened
up and it's just given the roots names
it's called the powerful and real so I'm
going to rewrite this like so so in
other words I've got some quadratic
equations and I know I should be able to
rewrite it such that it's factorize in a
form and I should work out what these
are and these might be messy they might
be nice numbers on there might be served
or something like that that's all fun
there's one little problem that I want
to adjust which is that this guy up here
because it could be any quadratic right
it could be done Manik right a could be
equal to not just one but two or three
or four or five or any number you like
but this guy is Manik right you notice
that if you were to extend all out in
the coefficient of x squared would be
exactly 1 okay so fix that up and make
sure that these things really are
equivalent I'm going to put a at the
front okay because once I multiply
through the coefficient of x squared
will be a so far so good
okay now here we're going to play this
mathematical trick which is so important
and you've been doing it for a long time
without even noticing it when you have a
look at one object from different point
of view right different perspective you
see different things but because it's
the same object you can draw different
conclusions on it right so I want to
think about each of these things
together but a purchase for this James
so the first thing is this second one
we've written to you okay if I look at
this guy and say oh I want to simplify
this out I noticed that even if ei is
there to make it the same as this right
through the same object if I now want to
go ahead and actually solve or factorize
whether expand rather the a doesn't
matter you see that I could divide both
sides by a and it would have the same
solutions do you agree so a simple
example over here right this parabola
here has related to a negative 3
yes if I would have slab of find out the
front what would that do to the roots
how would the roots change I thought
they would not change how with the
parameters I want to be different if I
put a spot at the front or like and
maybe one of the front yeah it's just a
little Venus promoted five before if
there was a five here and you expand it
all out these were the laundry sticks it
would be 30 right so this guy appears
really all the way stretched up here so
it would be 5 times taller and the work
if I've got a minus sign attention right
now when I am stand out this will not be
a 6 it will be our negativities so
steadily here is going to flip upside
down I can just see map anything before
so over here these two things have the
same solution that's a Shriner 100 or
minus 1 doesn't matter let's expand this
now ok we spent a lot of time a factor I
do last week and see spins she remains
the heart tell me what idea what's the
first time x squared
you're going to do that beam with your
kids that you ensure immunize right so
that means you next time will be - a
view of a dozen man yeah X then I'll
have to move on to the next tier right
so we will try again
and are you happy with that that again
now I have a look at this and then have
a look at this these things are quite
close to each other
do you notice I just need to rearrange
it's really both of these a little bit
and then structure will be revealed okay
so one of those posted here is I notice
there's some X Squared's and there's
some X's and then there's a constant
term at the end right alpha beta are
just numbers they're just something I
should actually say where alpha beta
Arts and Bruce okay
I can factorize this little further
right I can say x squared minus if I
factorize it like this
get all the X terms Delta where what
will be in these wrappings how many X's
am I taking away will you take away
alpha of them gr and then you take away
bit of them yeah that okay do you agree
in my factorization I pulled out a
negative and I pulled out the X as well
this alpha beta is just hanging out of
the room you can see just a number okay
now compare this with this and do one
more thing to this to make it look like
this namely remember when I went from y1
to y2 and I said let's make it what it
just to make it simpler the answers
don't say I can do the same to this
right if I divide everything through by
a just like I did here can you tell me
what to write for each individual term
what is this because it's just X when
what a district of
you divide by a right like you don't
know anything about these numbers so you
kind of simplify or anything like that
and then of course is an X and then was
that last term of Electrotechnical say
all right thankfully that zero just
stays zero okay now look careful look
really carefully look at this line and
then compare with this last line I have
it do you see these are the same objects
I put that for different points of view
what I can do is actually compare an x
squared up front and there's X's and
then there's a constant term but they
look different it was different right so
I'm going to say by comparing
coefficients
that's the name of all the numbers but
not X's or EQ in fact I can see how many
X's are there up here just X's is your
name right how many X's are then over
here there's minus alpha plus beta often
do you mean
what about this guy see oh no that's the
constant
how many constant herbs or what constant
says might have over here if alpha x
beat up get them in the same object so
now if I just read just reading is a
tiny little bit I'm going to multiply
both sides by negative one and we're
going to change everything to the other
side
I want you to look and I'm putting big
books around this with your another
column I want you to look what we just
read okay
what about for mater again then the
roots of this quadratic what this is
saying is if you add up the roots you'll
get this number whatever that happens to
be and if you multiply the roots you'll
get this number whatever it happens to
be let's test that out have a look you
need this all to start right you know
what the result you know what after is
your readers finalized on that which is
not important what is alpha plus beta
level of alpha plus beta
it's they give supersymmetry right which
is negative five
good morning lets you do this - fired
do you see where - five comes from have
a look at a and B why are they in a very
very first equation what a a is just 1
and B is 5 negative 5 over 1 which is
negative 5 does that make sense
what about alpha times beta the product
of the roots what's the point for the
roots for the first question it seeks
which sure not in December over here ok
physics Snickers so what's really really
interesting about this view you can work
out what these are without knowing what
the roots are equivalent to right like
you can go straight there I can read off
the sum of the roots from this I can
just say maybe five on one and I can
read the product of the roots just by
with you this number
right you don't even have to work out
what the product of the roots whatever
it's worth you can work out what their
price is immediately okay now this gets
really really funky and strange we have
a look at this over the roots on that
thing again
so Brisbane has been here the rift are
there right there are any rooms except
according to this work that we've just
sent here with a bit of fancy
factorization we can work out what the
sum of roots should be equal to sum of
roots should be minus B on a what might
be on a in this case a look - be on a
let's try / a there just to make it a
little clearer so - me on a will just be
negative to the prior truth I could work
out in the same way again without
knowing what the roots are it's just
going to be easy this guy over here see
my name which in this case is just for
now this is perfection to me because we
all said that these things don't exist
in ordinary you can't see any roots but
apparently you can add them up and
apparently you can multiply them which
is one of the clues that mathematicians
used you're essentially there are
routine you just can't see them on the
board you need something with a few more
dimension harder to detect